has Corner broken something no no
what's wrong honey you've probably
touched your triple bypass Burger mad
Stoney come to me
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome back to another trash taste
special
and for the first time ever we are going
abroad guys International trash taste
for too long we have commented on
America without becoming American
ourselves no so we decided for this
special we would do the most American
things we can imagine eating and
shooting guns I'd be enjoy it America
land of the free but how much we Trash
Talk Americans it would only be fair to
take part in their culture and what
could be more American than shooting
guns and eating enough food to kill an
elephant a first American challenge was
simple eat as much food as we could as
fast as we could and try not to die of a
heart attack this might be easier said
than done boys are you feeling pretty
hungry I'm starving I could destroy some
food right now great well this is the
perfect place because we can have a
burger here at all my burger but we
can't just have a normal sized Burger we
can try an american-sized Burger how big
are we talking about I absolutely have
no idea our producers have not told us
yeah so the producers have just taken us
here we don't know how big this burger
is going to be but supposing they're
calling it a challenge so it's a well it
has to be big enough so that it's bigger
than a normal American sized Meal which
is already too big for me so we're going
to struggle I'm just here to clog up my
cholesterol and my my arteries if I
don't leave here in an ambulance then
what's the point my doctor is still
concerned for me all right well let's
get to it then I just had a peek inside
and that thing looks vile oh oh my what
is that it's like the the if the table
is here it's standing roughly This Tall
did they just kill an entire [__] cow
it's like an operation in there it's
like an operator there's like two people
crowded around this thing I can't
believe I'm wearing a white T-shirt on
this day I'm an actual clown rip this
t-shirt oh my God all right oh
what is that are we gonna need another
meal this week thank God we have fries
for this I assume this is what they used
to kill the cow that we're eating right
now I can count there's six slices of
bread seven eight patties I feel like
I'm gonna get a heart attack just
looking at this let alone eating this so
what are your guys's strategy eat it
just eat it just hate myself for the
next 45 minutes I'm gonna take this cool
and calm I'm gonna have a nice time you
boys ready yeah I'm ready
oh three okay uh all right I just just
stopped oh my God where do I start maybe
I can like separate this I don't think
so I don't I don't think I can firstly
issue how do you even start to eat this
I'm gonna like separate this I'm just
going at it like that are you looking
for the bread there's plenty of bread to
go don't worry oh it's so hot oh you
have to like not think about it I
haven't even taken a bite I'm already
full just cutting this burger apart we
were all pretty hungry so the first few
bites were actually pretty damn tasty
which is good mail and win is our next
health check up in Japan what's the
lowest score you can get on the health
test guys I don't know but you're gonna
show us right I'm dead dead oh
I can't get it up at all right now we're
at the enjoyment phase of the foods
we're we're just legitimately hungry and
this is just a great lunch
as you can hear in the background we
have an ambulance on standby soon though
our bodies had hit their limit and all
that was left was depression oh my jaw's
getting sore it's because you're trying
to tackle it with two bigger pieces Joey
but they've got to go with the muffin
pork one piece outside man why are you
even trying I am trying
wow this is too much
help me help I'm [__] full guys it's
depressing
we have civilized meals here why are you
doing it like that how many cows died to
make this a lot I think this is a whole
cow right here I'm actually getting like
meat sweats from just how heavy this is
I hope this doesn't give me like a
permanent fear of burgers because I love
Burgers you're not going to finish that
watch me
this is a staple of food challenges we
get to the point where everyone stops
talking I'm like how do I be a YouTuber
anymore yeah I just make avocado do it
this is how vegans are born man I think
I'm gonna throw up soon
I'm actually not gonna lie don't say
that man like I don't even taste meat
anymore I taste oil and breathe
something just
the fries are really good
[Music]
he's just chopping it up in a small
little bit so it looks like there's less
it's just one bite I could do that 20
minutes left Stop doggy for a second
just stop talking for a second I gotta
think about this somehow eating a burger
has been one of the hardest things I've
ever done on trash taste the cycling
special was nothing compared to this
girl you look so sad I am sad this is
not fun what's wrong
what's wrong it's country even like a
nibble even like a nibble was like the
hardest nibble I've had in my life
Joey's channeling like all his Stoner
energy to like get through this man that
Stoney come to me
please I need
the Chow
that's a napkin it's time to stop I hit
the most burger patties so I'm like I'm
sure you didn't eat the most burger
patties that's Joey this is five six uh
four five six and I finished my fifth
and this is the sixth but I finished my
shape I can finish my shake too I'm
gonna finish surprising I'll finish the
frogs see it looks like he's winning
because he's hitting his Burger behind
here he put his Burger on top
see shut up he's still half a cow on the
[__] table guys I can see why
Healthcare is such a big thing in here
in America it was time for the judging
process but we all knew that the real
loser here was our cholesterol we need
you to judge who got the furthest is
that the furthest yeah who ate the most
look he's hiding some patties down there
it's close it's very close between these
two you guys yeah
it started bigger it started bigger than
mine
let's see I hope you feel good about
that wheel thank you I'm gonna go to the
morgue now how happy do you feel right
now oh it was not worth pushing myself
oh three patties was also like gross but
I was like so competitive that I was
willing to put my body in pain normally
I love pushing myself that's in the
context of exercise and pushing my body
pushing my body to try to eat more was
just
mentally and physically taxing sometimes
there are things that are not worth a
dub I think it's just depressing this is
a lot about Society this this challenge
but I guess that's all for our eating
why am I still eating the fries the
fries are so good the fries are amazing
fries are amazing but that's the food
challenge and now I think we're gonna go
and die but of course no American visit
would be complete without a visit to the
gun range we are going to be trying out
some guns this is the most serious
you'll ever see us take a special there
is no room to [__] around I feel so
American now I'm so excited I feel like
I need a hamburger right now just to
like feel the patriotism you know pistol
in one hand hamburger in the other hand
anyway we're gonna be shooting some guns
today we have a bunch of different types
of guns rifles shotguns pistols none of
us have ever shot a gun before we're all
kind of nervous I really don't want to
hurt me or myself or anyone else I
really hope you don't break anything
today today's the one day you should not
break anything please please Connor just
today just today we'll be fine I
couldn't have Apex Legends before this
I've got my CS go Skins so let's just go
and shoot some guns let's [__] do it
let's go
now we are not gun experts at all but
luckily we had some trained
professionals to teach us how to safely
handle firearms that would be even
Corner proof hopefully well I'm
immediately nervous are you guys I'm
intimidated just looking at guns like
you see guns and TV see guns and film
you're like that looks cool but like
seeing them in person are you [__]
intimidating I watched FPS Russia right
that's uh yeah
just like game of things just gamer
things I'm a bit scared I'm gonna enjoy
it too much you know what I mean you
know what I mean because then you'll be
like damn I'm in Japan I wish I could
shoot a gun or damn I mean like pretty
much any other country aside from
America where it's uh legal to own guns
it's gonna be like trying to shoot
anything water bottles come on puppet
our first job was easy just loading up
the guns is this your first time seeing
a real gun I mean I've seen a real gun
like cops carrying it around and stuff
are like not this close that one though
oh my God it's a sniper rifle in the
shape of a handgun they put a sniper
rifle and a handgun oh wow that's heavy
I mean it's metal I mean of course of
course it's heavy it just feels where to
hold this much metal in your hands we'll
load the gun in wrong that would be bad
shoot to myself it just comes there just
like a mini Bullet Bill right like that
like that oh no well I think you looked
at it the wrong way the other way
yeah he said it's really easy to put in
but it's really not I have that or I'm
weak this is way harder than I make it
look in the movies
it's the American Mario Party finish
[Music]
you only ever hear those click sounds in
games it sounded a bit too satisfying
when he clicked it and I was just like
oh oddly so oh that was like a really
satisfying sound oh no there's also a
paper in here that has a trauma plan
prage that we only need a Band-Aid today
hopefully nothing hopefully nothing yeah
although knowing how these special work
I'm probably going to be the first one
to injure myself somehow Connor please
break your streak of breaking things
please no choking today
you got it so perfectly though it just I
can't even tell yeah easy right easy
right okay guys give it a try as a gamer
I was up first to shoot the gun I feel
like whatever I'm gonna do it's gonna be
wrong I'm gonna stand back I'm getting
this let's let's start like all the way
let's go over the mountains make ready
that means loaded up okay Connor don't
[__] this up I'm not going to so just
this
I've never seen Connor handle something
so delicately in my life
get your sights lined up okay I'm so
nervous I think I'm gonna be more
nervous when I pull the trigger three
two one
[Music]
whoa Nice Shot Nice Shot got done when
you said three two one and there was
that pause there the trigger was like
didn't go down enough did you get the ax
I think I'd go close to the X yeah oh
yeah you kind of got it to the side yeah
it's nice nice that was nerve wracking
my heart is pumping man
that recoil is crazy he's not even
counting down anymore three two one oh
my god oh it's on the White
I can't get used to it everyone else is
like Stone Cold
[Music]
oh hit my head the jumping doesn't stop
slide locks back like that means you're
out of ammunition okay now you take a
look at your target got a ton of them in
the black that's right yes how's that
shooting it the first one was so scary
but the more you started doing it the
more you're like okay I think I got
control of the gun I'm kind of used to
it like a little bit obviously not
professionally but you know you get a
little bit of a feel I think we just
kept like every time everyone else is
like standing like completely stealing
me and Joey were just jumping every time
I definitely think being the one
shooting is less scary obviously next up
was my turn and to say that I was
feeling anxious was definitely an
understatement oh these are heavy aren't
they
oh my God
all right it's hot slowly increase
pressure on the trigger until it goes
boom okay ready
three
two
one
how does it feel your first shot Joey
how did that feel so The Recoil is
insane that's like the one with the
least real coil just breathe normally
Joey
how are you getting on the Block oh you
go oh there we go there we go you got
that you got it
oh
[__] hell Joey calm down
it's a natural look at this man you've
been playing too many video games
Joey's the IRL gamer man
all right oh it's some shaky dude
last stop was me and I'd be lying if I
didn't say I wasn't just a little bit
scared of the gun are you right-handed
or left-handed God oh okay sorry that's
right that's not a good sign okay hold
back
ready to roll okay guns Hot three two
one
that was it oh my God whoa watch out
what my hands are like shaking man oh my
God that was that's like so much
adrenaline pumping through your body my
grocery is pretty good though yeah yeah
yours is pretty good I got I got like
three in the middle so yeah mine was
just like all over the [__] place
Joey's a little more consistent than me
but I got some got some Banger shot man
maybe I should stop playing CS go do you
know why I was saying that correct
because uh I wasn't crouching so like
that I forgot to teabag after every shot
yeah it was time to dry out some pistols
with a bit more of a kick to them
needless to say some of us were still
not used to firing them yet pick your
favorite skin dude this is a pretty good
kid I like this one
three two one
safety for real this time three two one
oh that's got so much kick all right
that was bang on in the center oh
headshot baby one
look at the accuracy Joey what the hell
is that I just [__] in the chest and
then finish them off with a head shot
million as an American has never shot a
gun I really want to see mailing when
shooting a gun just [__] no you see
this in like movies and games so much
but doing it in real life must be
completely different yeah this is uh
this is a strange one
oh how do people get used to this even
if I've got ear protectors I don't got
body protectors you know my body feels
the shock wave
three I think she's down right there's
no safety there's no safety
boys trying to trick me all right
gone right there one
wow that kick is crazy that's powerful
enough to take down any creature in
North America
oh my God all right ready
oh my hands immediately got sweaty I
feel like you just gotta you know you
just gotta not like fear the gun you
know you've got to make the gun your
[__] you know guns don't kill people do
you remember that people kill guns wait
wait one
holy [__]
I feel good the feeling I have right now
is uh kind of like you know we have like
a good session of sex and then then
you'll sweat you're sweaty and the
adrenaline's just running through your
body it's kind of how I feel right now
are you saying that guns are like sex
I'm not going to say that but if you
wish to interpret it that way then sure
that's a bra moment all right let me try
and get a better grip
[Music]
all this excitement from firing guns
might have even been literally scaring
the crap out of me
[Music]
at a time like this really I was really
scared I was trying to time it with the
gunshot so no one can hear it God damn
it the guy literally scared the [__] out
of Joey it's scary dude look at it look
at that thing as if we weren't terrified
enough it was time for us to up the
power back in the slide
sound is so clean oh my god oh good luck
oh my God this is the scariest one yeah
never thought I'd be uh holding a
shotgun today no [__] that's scary
you don't even need bullets in that just
like [__] it and I'm intimidated I'm
like I'm like [__] running the other
way man pull it back and pull for it
that's such a satisfying sound I don't
know why three two one
what the [__] that recoil kind of looks
like he's holding an RPG
okay that was kind of cool
[__] they say criminals
oh
holy [__]
oh that's scary
it's fun though
oh my god get a look at that guy I mean
yeah a little bit look how red that is
oh [__] this is so scary all right three
two one oh wait hold on safety
Joey don't make me [__] myself mate
three two one oh that hurts so much
holy [__]
oh
no no no no no
you make it make that gun you're a [__]
okay okay good good I have to have the
right feeling about it yeah mine's red
yeah yeah mine's red
it's like if someone just came up to you
and just went like that yeah I guess so
it just like pushed you really hard yeah
like really hard and forcefully three
two one
you
I felt my life flash before my eyes then
man he's gonna fall in his glasses three
two one
all right oh my God oh my God
holy [__]
oh that sound never gets old I know it's
like sex all right come on yeah boy that
hurts look you're just getting beating
the [__] up I could definitely see why
this is the gun of like get off my
[__] loan like because I would I'm
[__] terrified holding nothing all
right well uh that's dead yeah whatever
whatever that was is is definitely dead
yeah what does it look in the back oh my
Lord so Connor's gonna shoot the
semi-automatic shotgun because he's
curious because one wasn't enough this
looks bad I'm the white guy here this is
okay so I don't need to do anything it's
already like loaded I'll just press to
go all right just boom boom boom three
two one
that was clean Dude triple kill yeah
that's pretty fun that's pretty funny
I can see where everyone like that
probably you did that in less than two
seconds which is awesome yeah let's go
nice three kills in two seconds but it
was time to up the ante again and end
things on some big boy rifles gentlemen
this is a Ruger Mini-14 semi-automatic
like the AR-15 but it doesn't look like
an assault weapon for according to
California it's not an assault weapon so
in their Infinite Wisdom the lawmakers
they said oh this is okay because it
doesn't look
yeah right
but it is semi-automatic just like that
I don't know if you guys have noticed
watching this but we are a lot further
away from the targets right now a lot
easier to shoot accurate with this so
you guys are going to be great so I like
less angle and then hold on
just like this angle flip it around oh
this way of course
let's go in the wrong way
oh my God my nerves all right this time
corner you got this third time third
time's the charm three two one
let's try the other magazine where's
that other mag Joey loaded it badly I
did it for you yeah and he did it wrong
has Connor broken something no no no you
loaded the mag you they loaded the mag
he just broke a gun
he broke a rifle well done three two one
[Music]
oh his safety's on three two one
oh really oh I just wanted to do that
did you hear that did you hit it yeah
I'm pretty sure I did all right good
luck who's next my time yeah Joey three
two one
I can't even see a hole you see a hole
oh that stuck so go ahead and pull this
back
this one feels way more casual somehow
than even some of the pistols yeah the
pistols have such a kick to them the
initial kind of shock is kind of big but
after that you can just
three two one
[Music]
nice
that was so much fun I think I get guns
now
[Music]
three
two one
I love the bolt the bolt is so much fun
it really feels like I'm shooting one
that cocking back and forth motion is so
satisfying one
[Music]
he's the number one tie Marksman it's
gone
look at the size of these things it's
like so you want to marry my daughter
huh this is the type of [__] that
Warlords make a necklace out one
[Music]
you feel like you're in a video game
yeah you're like I get it I get that
it's fun I hate to admit it it's fun
it's really fun golf these are
terrifying how big these are I would
probably blow you away May then come on
oh my God one
[Music]
holy [__] that's the point of entry and
that's the point that's the point of
exit the victims of today California has
all these strange laws one just makes it
a feature of an assault weapon making it
more dangerous cage up the front is a
flash hider makes it make less flash at
night right makes it an assault weapon
makes it dangerous pistol grip is
another feature makes it more dangerous
according to the California law this
looks like a video game this site it
doesn't look real
[Music]
I can see why California thinks that's
dangerous okay this is the most
dangerous thing I will ever do in my
life I promise mother
damn he's feeling himself man that is
way too fun oh my God
[Music]
oh it shouldn't feel that good it
shouldn't feel that good of course we
had to get our mum in on the action too
maybe you want to shoot mainly you want
to shoot your turn yeah it's your turn
go on he's loaded it up you should try
it
so our mum is uh gonna be shooting now
as well I was scared of the guns earlier
I think I'm the most scared seeing
Maylene hold that thing right now I like
how Maylin didn't want to fire the
pistols but I shoot as soon as she saw
this she was like all right it's my time
oh oh I see
very therapeutic okay but that's enough
for me no come on melee you're not gonna
finish it come on finish it finish here
come on
[Music]
I think it's done okay yeah it's done
how was that fun but very sweaty you're
always sweaty melee our first challenge
would be a game of gun darts we'd have a
single magazine to score as many points
as we could now I've played darts many
times never with a gun but I was still
pretty confident I could win let's see
if Connor can continue his gamer streak
I've played DARS with Connor he's only
good when he has a beer in his hand
that's true with all British people
Unfortunately today he has a gun in his
hand so I don't know how effective
that's going to be okay
that's not good that's not that's not
good scores at all wow oh wow I did not
do good you got 54 54. oh my God seeing
Connor absolutely choke on this
challenge that I thought for sure he
would ASAP I was definitely not feeling
confident all right he's loaded up he's
ready to go three two one he's gonna
beat you man he's definitely beating me
already going for that Bullseye a lot of
Wands but I think it's uh yeah you
definitely beat me I'm pretty sure wow
so the entire time I was aiming for the
bullseye all right and none of them hit
the bullseye but let's see yeah 89.
next up was my turn and
Garland has to beat 89 in order to get
the dog
uh it was a mess
that's it it's gonna be close that's
gonna be really close wasted the first
shot I think that was me getting used to
it I think you might have won this yeah
129. come on baby let's go
wait the protagonist power coming in
again I'm just the side character again
I've figured it out at the end of my
pistol session but you just need to make
the gun your [__] right just make the
gun your [__] what happened to making
your gun the [__] no because because
here like if you fear the pistol it's
just not gonna hit there it's just like
a video game you're just playing Call of
Duty I wasn't fearing the pistol and it
still didn't hit I didn't fear it I was
just bad with Conor and Grant tied at
one point each the final challenge would
decide who would be the ultimate winner
and the true American of trash taste the
game was simple we had three bowling
pins and a rifle whoever knocks them
down the fastest wins this was my chance
to fairly and clearly win my first
special all I needed to do was to not
choke someone's actually going first
this time so I don't know can you choke
if you go first probably probably maybe
you'll find a way all right give me a
three two one get ready three two one go
on corner
we're starting over he gets the practice
for loading it up and everything we've
all had a practice round we've all shot
this gun he's had two practice runs
that's not fair they say third time's
the charm it needs his third time three
two one
oh does that count I don't think did he
hit that
[Music]
11.84 I feel pretty pretty confident
about that it just like kind of knocked
over it didn't look like it got I
thought it was just gonna explode yeah I
thought it was going to explode it's
because they're little baby bullets
little baby I thought like the wind blew
that over no what are you on about I got
it the first one looked really sus right
the first one it just went it just went
no no no no no no no I was down a point
against both the boys and I knew I
couldn't win but I could at least ensure
that it would end in a three-way tie hey
shoot is ready three two one don't mess
up Joey don't mess up don't mess up
okay he's got it
[Applause]
oh he missed he missed he missed oh he
missed again what the [__]
oh we got it you got it I think oh he
got it okay
19.28
I [__] it up oh it was Joey that
choked
I thought I had that
that's that's dude Under Pressure that's
hard last up was me and this was my
chance to win it all would my
protagonist Powers kick in there was
only one way to find out Shooter's ready
three two one mess up mess up
the bullets in the wrong way
foreign
[Music]
like that you did not hit the second
okay look look our goal was to knock the
bowling balls over right what do you
think I think he should do that one over
again
oh damn it and finally I won my first
Trash taste special oh my it's insane
the gamer power the gamer Powers wow I
hit all of mine oh my God and in 11
seconds that's insane yes I actually won
fair and square I thought I was gonna
have to like prepare my lies to be like
what if it falls over that counts or
whatever but like I hit all of them
let's go can't even try to [__] his
way still not fast enough I am the speed
God is such a Negative still [__] is
that Connor's final challenge now there
is one final pin up there you have to
try and hit it no table support this is
just for like big dick points this is
big dick points yeah you better hit it
okay I can do this
come on one shot tonight three
two
one
whoa did you get it I think you nicked
the top of it oh
but that counts yeah that counts I'll
take it I'll take it we take those we
take those we take those can I shoot the
rest sure all right that's the real
reward you get to shoot the rest
oh he's missing and once it's in his
hands
no I'm doing a jury yeah it's a little
harder when you're holding it huh that
was fun this is great I should do this
more I feel a bit more free after that I
feel like I can drink a Budweiser eat a
Starbucks croissant maybe there's a bald
eagle somewhere around here that we can
tame I feel like today we've become a
little bit more American and me and gone
a little bit more so yes than Jerry yeah
you've got to pick up the pace
congratulations Connor you're finally
the gamer you finally won your first
trash day special for once there is
nothing we can say it's great it's great
to have my second W uh in a trash day
specialist while the cycling is okay
okay okay okay
I won and I'm kind of sad that I won the
one that has guns in it because that's
just why you guys kept joking about how
I look nefarious with a gun like that
you did you look terrifying listen I'm
just a gamer you know I got the reflexes
yeah it's really not fair you are like
the FPS specialist we had no chance guns
are scary and that's all right that's
all I learned from shooting guns and now
I hate Burgers yeah I never want to eat
a burger again after that no it was
disgusting but of course we can't do
these trash taste specials without your
guys's Support over on the patreon it
was fully funded by you guys over on the
patreon so thank you very much and hey
if you'd like to see more specials out
there because we have a lot more in the
works or to support the show in general
then head on over to our patreon
patreon.com trash taste links in the
description in fact four patreon to get
some extra not only behind the scenes
footage but an extra whole segment that
we needed to cut from this special we
filmed another segment with the race
cars but unfortunately thanks to Aer
Lingus [__] us up when we're in
America when we filmed we did not get
enough footage to make a segment we were
happy to put on YouTube so we've put
what we filmed on our patreon if you
want to see that segment so thank you so
much for supporting us and we'll see you
guys in the next trash day special bye
thank you
[Music]